Kanye West continues his anti-semitic
anti-jewish tirade he now is making the
claim that a Jewish doctor
misdiagnosed him apparently on purpose
wanted him to take pills which could
have then been swapped out I guess with
poison Kanye is very much unwell but I'm
going to tell you why this is so
important and he continues ranting about
Jews controlling entertainment and media
and medicine and on and on drove me to a
point of exhaustion which was
misdiagnosed by a I'm not going to say
what race what people uh doctor
and what hospital and what media went to
we know I can't say that
it was a Jewish doctor that diagnosed me
having a disorder that would have had me
on medication right now at a time like
this if I was on medication right now
then one pill could have been swapped
out uh-oh right so it's not even that
the the real medication that the Jewish
doctor wanted him to take was the
problem it's that if he was on the
medication the pills could have been
swapped it would be Michael Jackson and
Prince all over again right but because
they might put propofol in there I
didn't take the misdiagnosis
and I didn't take the the uh medication
I'm able to speak to you guys
clear of thought and transparency so
this right here is a chart of
uh Universal Studios 20 20th Century Fox
ABC oh my God is he pulling up
anti-semitic memes on his phone
snooze Columbia pitchers
our Warner Brothers ESPN sports Fox News
Washington Post let you go with my MTV
Music Television Nickelodeon USA Today
Wall Street Journal
now the thing is I skipped over maybe
about five of them because it was just
unclear on this list the red are the
executives that are Jewish okay so
listen
there's a lot of layers to this
it's very clear Kanye should be on
medication but I don't know what it was
that was being prescribed to him I I
can't say this enough
I know that he said or someone said at
one point oh Kanye has been diagnosed as
bipolar maybe it's schizoaffective
schizophrenia whatever
lots of those folks refused to take
medications okay
for so
he's having a mental health crisis
lots of people who have mental health
crises don't go to blaming the Jews so
we can't just say he's not really
anti-semitic he's just mentally ill okay
um it can it can be both things at the
same time he it's really common that
people find reasons not to take their
meds
for him it's because a Jewish doctor
wanted him to take the meds which could
then be swapped out with something that
could kill him
Kanye on his own saying this stuff isn't
really the issue the issue is the
alarming and extraordinarily large
number of people that agree with what
he's saying look at the comments on
YouTube under this video
and I am sure you will find people
agreeing with what Kanye says that's the
really scary part it's an important
thing to talk about he's not
anti-semitic because he's mentally ill
he seems mentally ill and he's
anti-semitic and the anti-Semitism is
coming out because he's uninhibited and
it's an important distinction to make
I'm going to be on Dr Rashad Ritchie's
show later today talking about it see
these clips on our Instagram at
davidpackman show and make sure folks if
you're watching this video right now on
YouTube
and you're not subscribed please hit
that subscribe button
one of our sponsors today is blue chew a
unique online service delivering the
same active ingredients as Viagra and
Cialis in a chewable form and at a
fraction of the cost and they're giving
my audience an entire month supply for
free so if you think you could benefit
from an extra boost of confidence when
it's time all you have to do is take a
short quiz on their website a licensed
doctor approves your prescription the
medication comes straight to your home
within days in a discrete package no
driving around to the doctor's office or
the pharmacy no waiting around no
awkward conversations with your doctor
all of Bluetooth tablets are made in the
USA the entire process is just a few
clicks go to bluetooth.com the link is
underneath this video they'll give you
an entire month's supply for free when
you use the promo code Pacman all you
have to do is pay five dollars shipping